but i don't know about you i find that
explanation very unsettling and very
dissatisfying because i'm like but but
but i don't do that on the second
morning i'm sorry on the first morning i
don't get out this tuesday socks because
i don't care about tuesday so i care
about monday socks so i will have you
know come tuesday morning i'll have
eight socks left and then seven socks so
even though this explanation actually is
true
i don't know just for me i don't know
maybe you guys are oh fine that clicks
for me doesn't for me okay i was not
satisfied with this explanation so
here's what we're going to do
yesterday we talked about the whole idea
of you know dynamic probability that's
what makes probability trees really
useful that's when they're useful okay
so we're gonna do a probability tree for
this one okay now you're gonna have to
follow very carefully here i'm gonna try
and explain
how to be smart about drawing
probability trees
because there are good ways and bad ways
to go okay
let's begin let's think about the first
um i'm actually going to think about
them not just as mornings i'm going to
think about those individual socks okay
so i need i need more space
and you're going to need more space too
so
rule off whatever you're doing
i'm gonna have a first stop whoops
a second
a third
and then a fourth okay so this is what
i'm going to go through
let's rehearse again from scratch okay
for the first sock that i picked here
are my choices okay sorry i haven't
picked that yet
okay so does it matter which one i
choose
still doesn't matter does it okay so
here's my first sock right so i can
actually pick any sock that is the only
probability that i'm interested in right
now if i were to draw this out like
actually i've got 10 to choose from but
i don't want to have a probability tree
that has 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
8 9 10 branches because even with one
level
let alone two three and four levels it's
already unworkable okay so i'm going to
condense it down what's the probability
of picking any sock
well just like before there are 10
favorable outcomes
and there are 10 total outcomes so far
so good
great
now i go to pick out the second sock
now
here there are two alternatives and we
need to consider them differently i hope
you'll see why in a second okay i'm
either going to pick sorry so i've
picked a sock now so i'll circle this
again
i'm having to pick a sock that matches
that one
it'll be the same
or i won't
it'll be different okay so
not the same
okay we've already worked out this part
of the question this is going to be one
over nine right notice the sample space
by the way can you see why i didn't just
write one i want to see this will be ten
this will be nine it's gonna be out of
eight it's gonna be out of seven right
build it in a way that makes the logic
easier to see not harder
that makes the complement eight over
nine so far so good
okay
now let's think about here
if i picked this is now this scenario
okay
i picked
a pair that matches
that's this morning here okay so that
was this one right
let's think about this now i have eight
choices does it matter which of these
eight that i picked for my third sock
it doesn't matter i'm in exactly the
same situation i was in the first
morning okay so therefore
going here i can pick any sock that i
like provided i picked a match the first
time right so this went ten nine this
will be eight out of eight
is that okay
i'll come back to this one in a second
let's complete what happens here because
it's easier okay
now just like the first morning i'm in
the same scenario right
how many socks are left well it's gonna
be out of seven
out of seven right i'm either gonna pick
a fourth sock that matches the third or
fourth sock that doesn't match this
third right i'll be in this scenario
again
same
oops
or not same
you happy with that idea how many socks
are the same as the one i picked out one
and then you got the compliment okay
excellent
now let's come down to this guy right
the game changes and this is why it's so
important to have the probability tree
okay
i didn't pick socks that are the same
right so i didn't pick a and a
i picked for example a and b
okay pause
does it matter which of the eight
remaining socks that i
pick and the answer is it does matter it
does matter it makes a difference okay
because if i pick my third sock to be a
oh i'm stuffed already
right there's no chance
having picked a on the second morning
because i already got a out of the
drawer yesterday as alien says it was in
the wash okay so there's a zero chance
if i pick this guy
it's impossible
that i'll get a match
a is not the only one which is the other
one
b if i pick b i'm similarly up the creek
i'm going to have to hide my socks all
day okay so therefore
there is two possibilities here
right
i can pick a sock that makes it
impossible to get a match okay so i'm
gonna call that
very doctor who i'm gonna call this the
impossible sock okay
there's a sock i can choose which which
gives me no chance of getting a match
right and there are two of them
out of eight okay two
out of 8.
of course you can write a quarter there
but can you see why i'm not all right
i'm trying to make the sample space
clear
so therefore you know obviously i could
write the complement of impossible
that's a bit of a double negative so i'm
going to write there you know i can pick
a stock that does make it possible i can
still get a match and because it's the
compliment six out of eight
so far so good
good
i forget about this guy now i'm not
interested in him because all i want i
rubbed it off all i want is a match for
the second morning so i don't worry
about him anymore i come down to this
one right
so i didn't pick one of these impossible
socks
right i've now picked out for instance i
picked out c that's a possible sock
isn't it okay
and then i've got two possibilities
i'm gonna get a match or i'm not
i'll either get one that's the same or
not the same
okay
what's the sample space well
there were ten socks here and then nine
and then eight and then seven right so
this is gonna be out of seven out of
seven because i've already pulled three
out
i picked c
color c how many socks are the same
one
and then the other six are different
okay
now what was the question i was after
i was trying to work out
what's the probability of getting a
match
at this point
okay so that's this one
that's this branch here
and this branch here right those are the
ones where i have a match on the second
morning and i don't really care what
happened on the first morning okay so
let's work out each one in turn and then
we can add them together
product rule to get to here additional p
put these guys together okay so what
would i call this one
i'd call it same same
two mornings same both times okay so the
probability of getting it same
twice right
is one times a ninth times one times a
seventh is that okay
one on 63.
seven times nine yeah
now i have a look at this one
what should i call it
i guess i would call it not same
and then saying that's what happens each
morning
so not same and then same
the probability is going to be
1 times 8 9 times 6 8
times one-seventh
four events right and they're all strung
together
i won't worry about the one i've got
eight over nine
times six over eight times one over
seven
i've got some fraction business here i
can cancel some stuff here i can cancel
some eights
right i get left with six on 63. of
course i could simplify that further but
i'm not going to
because i want to add these two right
these are my two possibilities i should
add them the probability of a match
the second morning
it looks to me like it's one on 63 plus
six on 63. that's seven on 63
so hold on a second
what just happens okay
we confirmed our original answer
sure enough it's a ninth okay but it's
weird
there's no replacement going on
it doesn't suggest that you would get
the same probability of a match the
second morning as you would the first
and the third and the fourth and the
fifth always the same
okay i think the reason why is because
subconsciously i think we're kind of
thinking of this
right it's like look look
i i want this particular event to happen
and then this one but actually there are
other ways for it to happen and when you
add them all up low and behold
you get the same thing okay
so the moral story is number one be
careful number two
can you see now that the diagram is
there
you can't argue with the diagram there's
nothing left out
every sock is accounted for every
probability is there you can see i can't
have gotten any of the probabilities
wrong on any of the branches because
look you can even see it counting down
right i have constructed my answer in
such a way that now you could pick this
up without my 15-minute explanation
and i hope it stands by itself
your answers need to do the same